I think one of the things that if we do
not address it now it'll only create
problems for both the team member and
the employer and the company
um which is uh it's it's a generation
that's actually very uncomfortable with
confrontation
right
um and you know disproportionately High
number of of young people who break up
with somebody who they've been dating
for four or five months by ghosting them
you know or they'd rather they'd rather
have difficult conversations over text
rather than in person if you're in a
relationship and you're fighting right
um and or leaving alternative voice
memos at each other rather than having a
conversation and so one of the things
that we're we're seeing is like I'll
give you real life example that I've
heard of a few times you know
um somebody quits in sometimes dramatic
fashion
um and sends an angry email that you you
don't appreciate me you don't pay me
enough
never occurred to them to Simply call up
their boss and say hey I'd like a raise
please
you know and that the choice between
having an uncomfortable conversation or
making that request in a in a
constructive way
is so uncomfortable that they choose
quitting
um uh and I've seen this happen a lot
um and so I think it becomes important
to us that if we aren't teaching these
skills of how to have uncomfortable
conversations how to speak up for
yourself how to talk about you know
creating an arrangement that may be
different from what my boss is used to
from the 20 years that they've been
working
and how we can work together to Fashion
the future of work if we don't actually
start teaching those skills and having
those conversations that what we what
we're going to end up with is people
just quitting because not because
it's a bad corporate environment it's
because they don't know how to have a
conversation
to talk about something that's
uncomfortable difficult or or make a
request it's really funny if you go back
to like the 50s or 60s
you never asked for a raise but you
didn't quit either you just remained
unhappy
right and then we reach a time period
where no no no no I'm asking for the
raise you know I've refused to remain
unhappy but we're now in a period where
um I I'm not going to ask for the raise
and I'm not going to remain I'm happy
I'm just gonna leave
uh which again it's an employee market
right now uh uh and so in the short term
yeah you'll probably line another job
and you'll be okay that again it's gonna
it's gonna find a balance is everything
we're living in a short term even if
short term is the next few years
um and I I think it's if we're talking
about helping people grow and become
better versions of themselves forever
then I think the skills that we teach
won't only benefit them and work it
benefits them at home in other words
that young person that we teach how to
have a difficult conversation and having
how to have an effective confrontation
so they can ask for a raise and probably
get it if they're if they're good that
skill set comes home too where I learn
how to have a conversation with my
partner in something uncomfortable
um you know that conversation that that
skill set goes to the way I treat my
children and treat my friends so we're
making better human beings here uh it
just so happens that it benefits the
company as well
um but but we got to teach the skills we
got to teach the skills